sind wir kurz davor dem größten rätsel
der physik der dunkle materie endlich
auf die schliche zu kommen
als mögliche kandidaten werden extrem
massereiche teilchen gehandelt im
italienischen zehn grad vom tunnel wird
derzeit die nächste jagdsaison auf diese
vips vorbereitet gelingt mit hilfe von
8,3 tonnen xenon endlich der nachweis
der dunkle materie klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
weltweit gibt es zahlreiche projekte die
der mysteriösen dunklen materie auf der
spur sind viele forschende gehen davon
aus dass die dunkle materie aus noch
unentdeckten elementarteilchen besteht
diese gehen wohl auf den urknall vor 13
milliarden jahren zurück wodurch das
heutige universum überhaupt erst
entstanden diese mysteriöse dunkle
materie teilchen sind der theorie
zufolge in der lage einfach alles im
universum einfach so zu durchqueren
diese eigenschaft hat die partikel auch
zu ihrem namen gebracht weekly
interacting massive particles will
übersetzt in etwa so viel wie schwach
wechsel wirkende massereiche teichmann
geht davon aus dass die auch als
schwächlinge bezeichneten partikel eine
große masse haben elektrisch neutral
sind und eben nur in geringem umfang mit
anderen teilchen wechselwirken doch
diese dunkle materie teilchen sind
bislang nur hypothetisch und wurden
einzig und allein vorhergesagt um das
dunkle materie problem zu verstehen und
somit wäre die entdeckung der nachweis
dieser prinz sicherlich einen nobelpreis
wert denn das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik beinhaltet kein einziges
teilchen dass alle eigenschaften eines
wurms vereint auch wenn die entdeckung
der wilms dieser hypothetische teilchen
tatsächlich eine riesige sensation wäre
scheint sie keineswegs völlig abwegig
ein vielversprechender internationaler
versuchsaufbau befindet sich in einem
unterirdischen labor in italien hier ist
man mit hilfe des detektors namens xenon
1 t auf der direkten suche nach dunkler
materie - 95 grad celsius kalte szene
befindet sich bei diesem versuchsaufbau
in einem riesigen isolier gefäß in dem
sich die wechselwirkung eines xenon
atoms mit einem
zum einen durch ein schwaches
lichtsignal und zum anderen durch
freigesetzte elektronen zeigen würde
letzteres hätte weitere leicht
verzögerte lichtsignale zur folge bei
signale sollen dem plan zufolge dann
durch hochempfindliche lichtsensoren
registriert werden sodass das
forschungsteam die freigesetzte energie
sowie den genauen ort des ereignisses
ableiten kann
bei diesem versuchsaufbau ist die
reduktion von kosmischer strahlung und
natürlicher radioaktivität eine der
größten herausforderungen doch auch hier
konnte bisher nur eins sicher
festgestellt werden falls es existieren
und tatsächlich dunkle materie teilchen
sind erzeugen sie ein so seltenes signal
dass selbst der empfindlichste und
größte detektor weltweit bislang nicht
in der lage war es nachzuweisen doch
jetzt wird den vips eine noch größere
falle gestellt statt den 3,5 tonnen
zenon die im vergangenen versuchs
durchlauf genutzt wurden sollen sich
jetzt mindestens 8,3 tonnen xenon den
etwaigen wilms in den weg stellen dazu
sagt der us-forscher raphael lang in
einem interview mit dem tagesspiegel
geladene teilchen von außen können nicht
weit in die xenon flüssigkeit eindringen
dank dieser selbst abstimmung bleibt das
innere volumen des xenos von
störstrahlung frei obwohl die xenon
atomkerne aus durchschnittlich 130
protonen und neutronen bestehen
zerfallen sie nur selten und verursachen
daher auch kaum eigene radioaktive
störsignale heißt also im klartext
sobald wild durch das kleine fliegen und
eines davon auf ein xenon atom trifft
wäre das ergebnis ein lichtblitz und
nicht nur dass dem zehn atom würden
elektronen entrissen werden und dieses
würde dann in seeon gas einen zweiten
lichtblitz zur folge haben beide
lichtsignale und auch der zeitliche
abstand indem sie auftauchen wäre ein
eindeutiges ergebnis nämlich dafür dass
wir es ohne zweifel mit einem film zu
tun hätten es gibt einige fachleute die
fest davon überzeugt sind dass wir den
bislang noch hypothetische teilchen
schon sehr bald auf die schliche kommt
so zum beispiel die astrophysikerin
kathrin heimann sie ist sich sicher dass
die empfindlichkeit der speziellen
detektoren schon zeitnah so gut sein
wird dass wir spätestens in zehn jahren
einen nachweis über den zusammenprall
eines xenon atoms mit einem
hypothetischen dunkle materie teilchen
haben oder aber eben auch schon sehr
bald und so würden nicht nur in italien
das wild gejagt sondern auch in den usa
hier sollen
einer ehemaligen goldmine ein tank mit
ganzen zehn tonnen xenon befüllt werden
auch china ist mit dem start im battle
um die entdeckung der dunkle materie
teilchen dabei hier ist eine falle mit
sechs toren geplant damit werden etwa
ein drittel der weltweiten
jahresproduktion von xenon eingesetzt um
der dunkle materie auf die schliche zu
kommen fest steht jedenfalls erst werden
wir in dunkle materie verstehen können
wir vielleicht besser verstehen wie das
universum entstanden ist und sich
entwickelt hat ihre entdeckung wäre
wirklich eine große sensation dunkle
materie spektrum erklärt anklicken
anschauen und spektrum video unbedingt
abonnieren sehr cooler kanal des
führenden deutschen
wissenschaftsmagazins in unserem
wissenschafts netzwerkes 1054 also
pflicht aber würde ich mal sagen bis
dann bleibt dran